o carro é meu nome é joe daniels sobre o
piano e hoje vim falar de viagens e
neste vício em viagens é tudo começou e
dizer que esse ficou tal maneira tão
entranhado que há dois anos seria deixar
tudo e sair à boleia deste local até o
bangladesh para ajudar as crianças da
fundação maria cristina e o nordeste
porque porque o a320 no bangladesh
apaixonei pelas pessoas pela pureza
ingenuidade do nordeste é o país mais
rico do mundo mas é onde moram as
pessoas mais puras e ingênuo e na altura
e quando cheguei lá não estava à espera
de ver tanta miséria
o facto de estar a comer na rua e as
pessoas barein simplesmente legal
poderão incluir depois tentava não comer
na rua porque não queria dar mais porque
um dia confusão ia perceber que as
pessoas anp conflitos com a uma simples
fotografia para tirar fotografias comigo
nunca me aconteceu na vida fazer um
filme é e eu fiz não porque era no
center um centro como mostrou nada disse
é porque viu realmente nos olhares que
ficam feliz como sempre fica um branco
em alturas como realmente porque no
banco deixando jackson feitas a maioria
das roupas que nos últimos anos as
crianças trabalham 16 horas por dia e
ganham 161 simplesmente e este vício am
que já tinha de viajar na altura já
tinha viajado crescente optimismo cria
será a aventura não tinham dinheiro não
tem também queria mostrar que não existe
dinheiro para sair só tem gostaram cada
país por si como o chile com uma tenda
andar de bicicleta como já fiz dois
gráfica e quando fazemos esta viagem que
ambos por conhecer o mundo é que o que é
na realidade que é o contrário de
conversar com tem nada contra o software
faz uma viagem confundiu e gostei muito
mas é é completamente foi contra o
resort e quando saímos para ver a
realidade
então chega um mês um ano estava no
livro com cervejas em portugal desde as
06 00 nelas leiria porque não dava aulas
de piano se a bola chegou a sair do
carro
pela áfrica ocidental há seis dias na
serra leoa nigéria congo possui pela
costa indica passando pelas malas sudão
burundês entra nesse momento estava no
livro e regressei porque ali um país que
o paquistão que é um país no mundo
quando temos embaixada nosso país que
nos fazem por terras nunca iriam fazer o
visto paquistão irã e turquia têm que
fazer capital e porque neste momento a
rota da seda
está um calor infernal eu tenho usado
pelo menos 30 gramas filho pequeno está
outro como estamos questão seja colocada
durante 23 meses e daqui a três meses
que a viagem se quiserem seguir e ajudar
as crianças que o cria uma plataforma
que é o dia que vem e compartilhando da
minha página facebook back muito reunião
e até o momento já consegui quase dois
mil euros para ajudar as crianças e é o
objetivo é tirar essas crianças
realmente da pobreza escravatura e
pressionando no futuro ou seja até 2011
que desde o irão até chegar a banda 10
pois fico lá um mês com as crianças
ajudar se confia também durante esta
viagem em angola e no quênia está com as
crianças e este vício das viagens
começou já há alguns anos e que disputou
realmente foi quando tive em cuba um
resort
por que por que eu não gostava time só
não gostava que eu queria então queria
sair para a rua e os empregados sempre
nos sites vão faltar no seu registo vai
lá aquelas coisas todas
e quando eu sei é quando eu gostava mais
que as pessoas entre pavão estava no
meio delas
gostava de kyoto de então a partida
decide fazer uma viagem até o egito
atravessar o deserto do sinai e em
israel
depois o após estas ea tyco e quantos
que é o egito e todas essas viagens
consegue perceber que os baratos vão
encontrar na nova zelândia ou islândia e
ea paixão pelas pessoas se apaixonar
somente em histórias engraçadas porque
eu costumo dizer o fim de minha própria
agora que sou uma palhaça do corpo
dolorido é verdade
e então comecei a piada totalmente as
pessoas pela presidente unidade e
algumas histórias que são completamente
diferentes nossa sonda que o fato dele
não de um outro júri ativo mas sim como
um raio de luz também os trending topics
em contínuo no congo às nove horas da
noite
mas trata uma trading um prato de massa
e todos começaram a sair ea gozar comigo
que vais pagar até agora eu sim então
foram chamados agentes foram chamados
empregado para chamar o tumulto e olhar
em primeiro na kellogg vai comer mas
agora está vivenciando agora da noite eu
como toda essa história com que o rito é
o mesmo tema esteve conosco e agito
aconteceu uma coisa que já havia
resolvido dentro ficou namorada de
acontecer uma coisa que foi o 5º andar
que melo e eu observei que meus planos
que temos que nos lembrar eu só quero
que meus a prova de portugal é bom
vê-los no avião não vou fazer um visto é
e tudo aquilo com o semiárido repente
com tudo o que é diferente do nosso
habitat natural que é que portugal é que
não estamos habituados há coisas que não
estão habituados outros
mande também é conseqüência da outra
parte que eles são chatos e chatos o
ponto de olharem pra mim então ver
aquelas kita e assim é um dos que te
chamas casa lá é tetra obrigado e outro
em dinheiro muito dinheiro porque a
partir disso nomes que também não
perguntei nada chegou uma altura que
serão tão chatos que o tornem frio eu
tinha me olhar para o chão porque já
sabia que não íamos aquilo era o deserto
área adversária em dinheiro após ser
prometidas e quer um banho ou seja fique
frio e rio com essa história depois que
o sudeste asiático e sudeste asiático é
barato hoje em dia não sei quê mas já
foi há dez anos
gostei realmente a sociedade desde a
cultura de estudo e histórias engraçadas
na história de como entrar num autocarro
que sempre renderam ao camboja onde é
que eles vendiam bilhetes mais óbvio
aquilo com queda de pasto no meio do
autocarro o que era super giro que
quando o autocarro travar todos os que
ganham em cima dos outros ea e pronto e
toda essa história não é comecei a
gostar e cada vez mais somente as
pessoas e das crianças superior gosta
alunos e gosto criança porque acho que
sinceramente que são mais por isto nós é
muito mais puros mãe em gênero e não tem
maldade e pais têm processos e atitudes
mais umas quantas viagens pois vale
alguns saltos e o salto foi de que eu
fui lanka
alencar há dez anos atrás não tinha
turismo
as crianças reclamavam do carro
de um balão da banda quer dizer branco
am e de repente aconteceu algo que nunca
tinha acontecido
quero ser fotografado pelas pessoas
ficam no bangladesh ou seja eu andava na
rua e quando dava contas terão os
imóveis terá uns três dias algumas
crianças no autocarro para tirar
fotografias e era algo que eu realmente
não estava habituado é essa simpatia
tudo por um homem quando nós viajamos e
vamos ter por 1 a 1 com a bolívia
estamos a tirar e fez as suas coisas
traz canção inter no méxico e na
guatemala são mais não ia ao contrário
terá 13 15 min depois aconteceu o maior
salto que é que também queria mostrar às
pessoas que o utilizam muitas vezes
mostra e eu fico chateado lixado muitas
vezes pintam o mundo de forma tão
injusto e ingrato é que eu acho muito
mal então viajei até o irão a vida já
transmitiu o inimigo quer ouvir uma
palavra irão ficaram logo os estados
pronto estou vou matar-te uma pancada
por agressão todos os turistas e tetra e
quando saíram antes de explicar o que
aconteceu só poder que o irão é o país
mais hospitaleiro mundo há mais de dez
anos por todos os sites do mundo em
bloco viram as suas inflavam não com o
objetivo de criar dinheiro mas
simplesmente sabendo que eu era muito
não falava inglês mas guardar fome e
prejudicando por um terremoto de 5 graus
do irã de produzir sabe que os
acidentados pensão deus então primeiro
dia apanhava um táxi
queria pagar e eu não aceitava dinheiro
ea chama plano e só amanhã vamos deixar
um dia a mesma coisa o de ser a mesma
coisa levou as pessoas paravam com uma
criança criança que andava na escola
quer saber falar inglês era que um dia
os meus pais minha família queremos dar
as boas-vindas obrigado por todos aqui
então o irã foi identificar do mundo
realmente que muitas vezes é injusto e e
e cruel entre as coisas eram
completamente amáveis e quando eu sei
você ganha coragem de viajar para países
pouco famigerados em países como iraque
paquistão afeganistão e viajei tampouco
é questão de poder a equipe novamente
que a televisão e as notícias mostram
também coisas mas não é só mostrar
coisas margem para continuar a assistir
a três meses com a semana
a faixa de gaza então estava sendo
molhado e os envia mensagens colegas
meus amigos mas mãe tá seguro e é um
problema que acontece quando um destino
é que a televisão só que naquela rua e é
o que mostra a cara para fora e isso
acaba por ter uma imagem que muitas
vezes não é não é bem assim
essas pessoas vão à mãe de deus da
guerra e da guerra onde confecções
pessoas mais amáveis que encontramos não
é o iraque 10 acho que a tatuagem
nunca vi tanta que os jogos entre mal 1
100 portuguesa espetacular neste momento
porque o pequeno ronaldo da porta
enfim o grande embaixador do paquistão
também foi muito giro
os policiais controlavam vamos pagar
chato não habituado mas já tinha
conseguido se lanka ser cravado por um
clube se cria um cigarro que não ligaram
em nenhum momento nós não estamos
habituados a isso não é comum se não é
que eu não gosto que me esqueci contava
entrar no autocarro e de repente o
autocarro tal fazer uma corrida com
outro em termos batido eo rio claro que
o rio está um holandês também porque
olha porque não estou a ver a apanhar é
que o autocarro da rede expresso viseu
porto e agora composite schumacher senna
um com o outro é no paquistão am eu vou
falar rápido são muitos times mesmo
aconteceu uma história de que podem ver
em sua idéia de empresas foi o entrei no
avião
tampe palma e havia muitos paquistaneses
em um pomar com o objetivo de ir é a
meca na arábia saudita então eles vão
ter aumento do espaço fronteiro pelo
menos uma vez na vida têm química e
muitos nunca tinham haviam então é bom o
meu lado com a vontade do ex tenente um
deus perguntando aos primeira mão o que
era é que o objeto que o hospedou o que
eu tenho aqui um erro e demonstrou isso
é um mostrador demais aqui para mostrar
seu filho seif água e ouviram a fifa
envolvem música e poesia televisão e os
outros dois pediram que eu também
crianças que terão em vez de ficarem no
deus não tá moderado do outro então
perguntaram quais a porrada da outra
coisa para tirar o filho tirava até
final os poderes para cada um cada um
tem o seu
em nota a empresa das pessoas nunca
viram nada nessa viagem continuirá que
passei pela turquia na zona do curdistão
entre 115 francês e na altura há seis
anos eu achava o tejo
e falo porque ela ia de bicicleta desde
a origem até o atendimento só que o
conselho já tinha viajado muito ouvir a
história da áfrica e que os com tamanho
da cabeça que foi numa altura por acaso
que lecionava que não pagavam não tinha
muito dinheiro então o que eu sei fazer
é comprar uma viagem portugal e fazer
bicicleta até a guiné bissau mas ainda
também foi prometida viagem que uma
estreia que mais sofri não estava à
espera de tanto calor do peso ao forte
novas sombras não verá muitas vezes das
pessoas nos postos e e áfrica é um
continente onde social sims social tal
maneira que os polícias todos uns querem
roubar a seleção todos corruptos e que
observou uma tal forma que jogamos 50 e
dá uns óculos da mistura não há outro
quer sentar 600 empate chegar à
convenção português e etc
e eu sou tão curto que arranjam maneira
para tudo seja uma vez um flamengo com
deus cuida disso é que a atormentava a
troca direta da conversa mas
infelizmente aqui também se vê muitas
situações não é que as pessoas não só o
senegal costa do marfim mali anos não as
crianças e querem que nós vamos às
crianças que estudam em portugal porquê
porque eu é triste mas é o facto como
nós consegue sustentar então preferimos
dar às crianças que nós fizemos e apesar
de tudo os povos nas aldeias as pessoas
são super que o supermaiô é alta quando
fiz a viagem agnelli bicicleta foi com
um amigo meu e uma altura lembro que eu
sempre dei uma informação uma direcção e
aos todos os emocional fala francês
em alguns a lei fala de bola quando
falava francês de março em frente sempre
em frente a uma altura de são miguel
acho estranho porque acho que é pra que
eu não estou aqui para isso espera aí
não parei um pé dos nativos e disse olha
aveiro aveiro e guarda tudo ai eu achava
já possui vocês não sabem nada mas não
sei explicar
só tem dois minutos tendo mesmo vou ter
que avançar e esta viagem ou seja ela
cantava com tribos
o giro das pessoas dizem pois não se
fala não sei quantas línguas e as
línguas não tem nada a ver não é porque
aqueles sinais comuns não parava nas
tribos e parava por causa dos danos e da
chanan quero dormir dentro da chaminé e
fazer o sinal e o chefe do lakers e boas
feira o senhor mais de 12 da permissão
para dormir e ea via expressa engraçadas
contar com erros não falar em francês e
toda noite eu falar em valor fazer olhos
nariz cabeça pronta e aprender aquelas
palavras e e pesa o fato estamos abrindo
a porta como na guiné bissau na guiné
bissau nunca paguei domina as pessoas
abriam as portas da onu comida
não dá para falar muito mais vou avançar
pois pra outra viagem foi do quê né
o ning e vou contar uma história que
alcides pensamento não entra nada para
lhe ser bonito ou feio ao observar que
todos querem casar porque vem nós um
passaporte
então ele estava no reino das bicicletas
foi pouco então se deparado e chega lá o
rapaz mas eu perguntar o que tem que
fazer conta a história de cigarros e foi
comendo havia passado morava em outros
com frango não convidaram eu sei o que o
paraná é pioneiro cunhou entra na loja
comecei como meia pois agora tem que
casar com ela
o que ela falar sério e eu tentar
desviar a conversa se casar com ela o
leva para portugal e aí nunca ter amado
e eu tentava não dar muita importância
que não é muito mas é a primeira vez que
você olhar para raparigas sem olhar pra
mim e há maneiras nem era feito que era
esperado que ela tenha mais produtivo
que se nossa tem comigo tem que fugir
tem que ter que ir embora
de tão sei que vou fumar um cigarro
quando ela consegue penteava sabe que
tentar fazer meu das marcas como é que
os nossos filhos pensa mesmo em cada
qual estamos a falar em filhos de tudo e
pronto e chegou ao fim e todos o pronto
todas estas viagem nesta composição
viagens que fizeram com que eu ficasse
realmente viciado não existem muito
dinheiro como digo é prestar só para
discutir como agora não é com esta
viagem tendo a boleia
acabamos por ter histórias engraçadas
que as pessoas têm pelo menos abrir a
porta
voltemos a à porta das igrejas deixamos
a campari
e é e pronto daqui a dois três meses
você queira viagem desde o irão até o
banco e depois ficou a china as crianças
quem quiser ajudar as crianças podem
visitar a página do facebook que beck 81
e daniel fazendo antigo
basta um número 2 não tenho o nome a uma
opção pode ser anônimo e pronto e vou
acabar uma maneira que uma pessoa onde
acabou comigo também fez com que já se
mudar
hoje em dia no do valor em bens
materiais foi meu pai eles vão ser que
não falava ficam deliciosas a vida
precisa todos vós usar a vida e obrigado
[Aplausos]